[Applause]
good afternoon good after that was lit
okay so good afternoon everyone yes I'm
Carrie Jordan executive director for the
carpentries and this is my beautiful
afro textured
hair thank
you so while AFR textured hair and data
science may seem like two unrelated
topics some intriguing similarities are
worth exploring so in my short talk I'm
going to share a few interesting
similarities in hopes that by exploring
them you'll be inspired to embrace
diversity creativity and collaboration
in your R
projects so here's a quick overview of
how we'll spend our time together I'm
going to give you a little bit of
background about myself and my journey
to data science from there we'll get
into the bulk of my talk and I'll tell
you about some organizations that I love
that are doing the work to advance
equity in data
science now it can be very difficult to
step away from life I have a
three-year-old I'm sure you've seen her
roaming around the
[Applause]
conference it can be difficult to you
know step away and be present in the
moment in the moment but I want us all
to take advantage of this opportunity I
want to set some agreements I want us to
agree to give each other our undivided
attention and to also agree that this is
a welcoming and inclusive environment
and though I'm the person that's in
front of the room we're all going to
learn a little something from each
other and let's agree that we we're
going to share at least one thing that
we learned today with someone else can
we agree Perfect all
right so after earning bachelor's and
master's degrees in mechanical engine
engineering I decided to pursue a PhD to
address the fact that there weren't
enough people who looked like me in stem
I read an article in the Harvard
Business review and the name of the
article was called stop telling women
they have impostor
syndrome and so in this article they
explained that my illusion or my feeling
like an outsider it actually was not an
illusion it was the result of systemic
bias and exclusion so rather than
complain about you know bias exclusion
all the things that I've been through
growing up in Detroit I chose to be part
of the solution and so I joined the
carpentries team in 2016 and I've been
advocating for equity in open science
ever
since one night I was decompressing as I
do and I came across this documentary on
Hulu called the hair
tals so in this documentary it was a
group of women who were sharing stories
celebrating black women's identity
Beauty culture and Humanity through the
lens of their hair now afro textured
hair or black hair is common among those
with Bloodlines leading back to the
tropics and subsaharan Africa each
strand grows in sort of a helix shape
and it appears denser than straight hair
and for that reason it can be
in unlimited
ways I got through about half of the
first episode of the documentary and I
thought to myself black hair and data
science have a lot in common I wonder if
people know that and that is the reason
I'm here today to tell you about those
things so call and response because it's
me and I can't help myself give me one
word that describes your hair AB
abundance yes beautiful what
else color you said gray
[Laughter]
shiny versatile what
else
shorts good to see
you well in the last 40 years my hair
has been on a journey from pressing curl
to braids to Locks and if I had one word
to describe my hair it would be
complex my data science Journey has been
as wild as my hair Journey okay super
complex lots of twists and turns trial
and error consultations with friends and
colleagues and trusted advisors I
started using spreadsheets I learned
SPSS or I did I learn it actually I I I
don't think I learned it I used it I
used
it I used
SPSS and now I'm dabbling in
R by appreciating the parallels between
AFR textured hair and data science and
identifying the tools that you can use
for both you can get involved with data
science to solve problems for your
community and any problems that are
important to you so those are the
parallels that I'm going to draw for you
today both AFR textured hair and data
science are complex AFR textured hair is
known for its diverse textures curl
patterns and unique styling needs
requiring a deep understanding of its
intricacies similarly data science deals
with complex data sets requiring
analytical skills to extract insight and
solve
problems afro Ed hair is incredibly
diverse ranging from tight coils to
loose
waves likewise data science involves
working with diverse data sets data
sources data types such as structured
unstructured data multimedia data both
domains require an appreciation for the
variety and richness of their respective
elements styling AFR textured hair often
involves creativity
adaptability catering to individual
preferences and changing Trends okay
y'all remember uh finger
waves
listen moving
on data science similarly demands
creativity to ADI to devise Innovative
approaches and adaptability to handle
evolving challenges in analyzing and
interpreting dat
data AFR textured hair has a Vibrant
Community with individuals sharing tips
experiences and resources and similarly
data science thrives on collaboration
we've heard a lot about that at this
conference collaboration knowledge
sharing with professionals working to
tackle complex problems and advanced
fields now maintaining and caring for
AFR textured hair involves learning new
product products new techniques and
styles and similarly data science is an
Ever evolving field that requires
continuous learning staying up to date
with new algorithms new tools and new
methodologies AFR texured hair has
historically been underrepresented and
marginalized in professional settings
but there's a growing movement for
inclusivity and embracing natural hair
especially in the
workplace in data science there's a
similar push for representation and
diversity to ensure that different
voices and perspectives are
included leading to a more hopefully
Equitable and inclusive
outcomes AFR textured hair is a distinct
and beautiful expression of
individuality and cultural
heritage similarly data science thrives
on diverse perspectives and experiences
to uncover unique insights embracing
different viewpoints in both Fields can
lead to Innovation and problem
solving so we get the point right AFR
textured hair is often difficult to
categorize and some would even say
difficult to manage because it because
of its many variations including pattern
pattern size density strand diameter and
field similarly data science is often
difficult to Define and some would even
say difficult to navigate learning
because of its many intersections from
statistics programming analytics and
other domain
knowledge now in caring for black
hair having the right tools and products
to maintain your qu is super important
and the same can be said for data
science once you've established that
firm foundation and reproducing ibly
cleaning your data hint hint okay
organizing it etc etc it's time to
choose a tool to manipulate your
data what tool is right for you to
manipulate assess and analyze your data
should you use open- Source tools like
r& python or stick with proprietary
tools like
SPSS to help I turn your attention to
the Andre Walker hair typing
system so hair stylist and businessman
Andre Walker is known for maintaining
Oprah Winfrey's hair for decades so if
he did Oprah's hair clearly he got
something going on he's also known for
creating Halle Berry's pixie cut in 1997
he created a numerical grading system
for human hair
types the Andre Walker hair typing
system classifies AFR textured hair as
type
four there are other types of hair
defined as one for straight hair type
two for wavy and type three for curly
with letters a b and c used to indicate
the degree of coil variation in each
type so here's an assignment for you
what is your hair type yell it
out 2
b
I'm I'm a
force I love it so I use this system
don't worry don't worry I'm going to
make the table bigger for you I use this
system to break down all of the
different data sets that we see in data
science and what programming languages
or tools we could use to run this
analysis for the sake of time we won't
use the whole table but I have a QR code
at the end cuz I spent a lot of time on
this table and I do want you to I want
you to look at it later but for the sake
of time we're going to focus on type
four we'll F focus on type four because
that's my hair
type so if your hair is type four like
my hair it's tightly coiled with no
defined pattern and I equate that to
working with super messy data like text
Data word words sentences paragraphs of
free flowing text it's unstructured it's
not neatly formatted into columns and R
is a fantastic tool to learn and to use
in order to devise patterns from this
type of data Trends make predictions and
recommendations you can use it to
predict traffic Tick Tock algorithms and
even detect unusual Bank
transactions so I'll summarize
like afro textured hair there are levels
to this thing that we call data science
and to break into it successfully you
have to build a strong Foundation by
learning about different types of data
what repositories are out there how do
you share and collaborate with others
how do you clean it format it Etc once
you have that foundation so you've
taking care of your roots you have to
determine the tools that are right for
you to get the kind of anal analysis you
want is it a pressing comb is it a latch
hook is it braids what are you doing
with your
data whether you're using spreadsheets
for numerical operations or you want to
jump into the 4B that unstructured data
that that not neatly formatted data and
use a tool like
R these are a few broad comparisons but
it's important to note that AFR textured
hair and data science are distinct and
separate
domains how however exploring
connections between seemingly unrelated
topics can of often lead to new creative
insights and
collaboration putting this all together
I want to introduce you to a few
organizations that are doing the
work these organizations are using their
data science skills to positively impact
black and brown people's lives
worldwide the first organization is data
for black
lives data for black lives is a movement
of activists organizers and scientists
committed to using data to create
concrete and measurable change in the
lives of black
people through their research advocacy
and Community Building they support the
vital work of Grassroots racial Justice
organizations to challenge
discriminatory uses of data and
algorithms across systems they have a
national network of about 20,000
scientists activists those who are
building a future where data and
technology is used for good rather than
instruments of Oppression in the black
community the second organization is the
algorithmic Justice League and this
organization leads a cultural movement
towards Equitable and accountable
artificial
intelligence their mission is to raise
public public awareness about the
impacts of AI equip Advocates with
research to bolster their campaigns and
to build the voice and the choice of the
most impacted
communities they Galvanize policy makers
researchers industry practitioners to
mitigate AI bias and
harm and of course the last organization
is the carpentries
because
yes we are are the leading inclusive
community teaching data and coding
skills we were founded to teach
foundational computation and data
science skills through short impactful
workshops and our model is to train the
trainer we certify volunteer instructors
and they go out into the communities
that where they can reach people
directly with these data skills our
course material is open source it's free
to use it's free to contribute to and in
this way we're able to scale beyond our
organization and build Regional
self-sustaining learning
communities so here's your call to
action whether you choose to believe it
or not data is affecting your life every
single
day from whether the TSA Pats your hair
down at the airport which they do me
every single time I fly um to what
content appears on your social media
feed it's in your best interest to learn
how to work with data and encourage
others to no matter your field of
expertise I'm sharing a few resources
that I want you to watch including the
hair Tales documentary it was really
really good read and
visit keep in touch I think we have time
for a couple of questions and thank you
so much for your attention
[Applause]
today
all right so a couple questions for you
for those of you with slido open please
remember you can upvote questions help
me decide what to ask here so first up
how do you as a black woman deal with
the inherent subconscious exhaustion
that comes with continually showing up
and working towards better
representation yeah starting small right
I don't
know happy hour is no I'm just kidding
no you know I'm hon with myself and I'm
honest with my colleagues now I I do
have a therapist and I go to therapy
every two
weeks and I think you know I think
mental just mental health in general is
more understood now than it was even 20
years ago when I was in graduate school
and I have these conversations often
with my therapist and then you know a
close group of people but then I also
ask myself what's important to me you
know if I'm being asked to do all the
time can you speak can you Mentor can
you do all these things sometimes I want
to do it because I have a connection
with the group or I have space but
sometimes I don't and it's okay and I
pass it off to other people that I know
would like those
opportunities okay fantastic next up
what changes would you like to see in
the data science Community to increase
representation and better support
diversity I think language is is super
important I think the blank statements
that I hear there are no black women
doing X or there are no you know trans
people doing why I think we have to get
away from using these very general
statements and get creative one thing
that we do at the carpentry is we know
we aren't the end all Beall organization
and so we try to partner with other
organizations who have more access to to
different communities that we want to
work with and I think it's the same for
individuals you know I don't have a I
have a large community of black women
who have phds like I could name 10
people right now 10 black women right
now who have phds because that's the
community that I belong to but there may
be another community that I don't have a
lot of experience with I'm going to go
find them I'm not going to create
something from scratch so I think that's
that's super helpful not trying to do
everything on your own but collaborating
with
others okay fantastic and uh let's see
sorry y'all
my hair is hitting my
[Applause]
mic all right um uh this is a fantastic
analogy have you considered expanding
this um as a a longer talk or longer
tutorial to welcome new people in I have
so this is the second time I did this
talk I first did it at Spelman College
and of course it was received well
because it's a historically black
college all women you know historically
black college so it was definitely
received well I tweaked it a bit for for
this audience but I have been thinking
about kind of expanding it a little bit
more because it seems to resonate with
more than just you know black women so
that's that's pretty dope all right
fantastic let's thank Carrie again thank
[Applause]
you